[Music]
hello everybody and today we're going to
talk about powerful bishops and the idea
called windmill the tactical idea of
windmills so first and foremost I want
to warm up with a small puzzle between
Tony miles and Walter brown can anyone
tell me who Tony miosis does anyone
remember No
so Tony miles was one of the greatest
British players won one of the greatest
British player of all time until short
and Adams came by and now we have Kevin
Jones and Tony miles was the real
eccentric he even played on a massage
table once while drinking milk it's
important that he wasn't drinking milk
so apart from being a chess eccentric he
was a really imaginative attacking
player and let's try to solve this
puzzle
that actually miles executed and won
against Brown Walter brown who was the
American who was an American ship wait
he played for America not sure yes yes
so he was American champion as far as I
know yes so it's six times champion
thank you so Walter Brown who was
six-time champion um Tony Myers to move
and play a splendid sacrifice
yes King page takes a 767 teenage five
king g8 so let's go back a little bit
obviously what we'll try to clear up the
route for the rook so the Rope can get a
checkmate so indeed Bishop takes 8 7 is
the first move King takes Queen h5 King
g8 and how should we continue this
attack Bishop takes g7 yes so this is a
brilliant brilliant sacrifice by Tony
miles
this is a double Bishop sacrifice which
is kind of rare in modern chess but if
you look back in chess history this was
seen before but it's still nonetheless
spectacular so the black king takes g7
and now we need to try to box in the
black king so we can give a beautiful
mate for pot yes yeah Queen g5 King gage
eight rooks e3 but that falls into one
little trouble that the bishop will go
to e4 and just in the nick of time will
help and when we would give a check the
bishop is just there to cover up so we
don't want to give black some helping
hand
yeah no but it is a queen move Queen
eight-six is almost the move but there's
a more precise one yes yes King g8 can
will someone explain to me why Queen f6
is such a brilliant idea
yes rooks b3 okay obviously there's two
possible moves either rook c3 or rook c4
and I always do this but
I'm going to do it again let's vote
should we play rook c3 or look c4 and
then I want to volunteers for both
saying why this and then the other side
by that yes
okay so let's vote
who says rook c4 one two three four five
six seven I cannot count so many yes
Wyrick c4 and not rook c3 mm-hmm
this Brooke c4 you're saying we're
cutting off any defensive ideas for
black right
who says Brooks III nobody good good
class so if you would play Brooks III
then he would play what what is the
defensive idea for black yes yes and the
bishop saves the day yet again because
even though we would check the bishop
covers then if root age three if root
age three then Bishop age seven covers
Nate again and no mate that's sad so
which one was the move then
rook c4 yes and no more Bishop c4
trickery and this is way way easier than
Brooke sees me so the next move is going
to be root G four and it makes so we
learn that the bishop there the bishop
is a good sweeper and the bishop the
bishops can attack from afar then now
comes the idea of windmills can anyone
tell me what is a windmill tactic yes
yes and yeah basically you said that you
keep on checking and taking huge amounts
of material and what of what do we do
with this I'm sorry ah which pieces we
used for windmill yes no yes
yes what did you say
rooks and bishops indeed I heard
different variations but windmill is
usually used limit windmill tactics its
windmill tactics and it's rooks and
bishops basically giving checks multiple
checks and winning lots of material but
I'm going to give an example so you can
see and prove prove me how we could use
the windmill tactics so in this position
this is actually the first classical
example of venmo tactics here Oscar one
of those chess legends who Fisher
Youssou we call all the time is actually
losing to a Mexican legend called Torre
Repetto who actually has a Tory Memorial
annually and Mexico so here it might
seem that we have pinned and that we
cannot move the bishop because if the
bishop moves then they'll take our queen
but is that true can we use the windmill
for the first time in history yes bishop
eight-six that doesn't work at the
moment because the idea is good but then
they take rook takes I guess and we can
gauge it and we cannot continue giving
checks yes yes Bishop f6 this was the
brilliant idea of Torre and now black
take takes and now somebody please let's
start giving windmill checks yes yeah
you
Luke takes f7 check King g8 yes yeah
King h8 yes yes rook takes v7 King g8
how can we continue our annual windmill
yes yes engage eight and I think it's
about high time we win more material
okay someone is saying that we should
win more piece how can we win some more
piece yes
rook takes even on a seven greedy greedy
King g8 yes
rook g5 and basically Tory took
everything possible on the seventh ring
like ski and now we take the Queen yes
and that's how Tory beat Oscar so it's a
valuable idea to know how it's a
valuable idea it's a valuable idea to
know our windmills work therefore I came
up with three studies of my own on
windmills it's not a super famous study
because I just did it few weeks ago so
this is the super famous one not yet
known but it's going to be super famous
this is I'm going to made three types of
puzzles they will look really similar
but the solution is different all the
time I did some work okay
it's my to move and when with windmill
ideas yes no yes
yes ship f6 that wins but not with a
windmill idea yes what Queen h6 yes G
takes h6 yes King g7 King age 7 to
engage it and now we're reaching the
critical moments then we will need to
know where we want to take material or
mating for some reason I'm warning for
mating maybe I know the solution oh yes
yes
check again King GA Luke c7 that's a
little bit early because why does Luke
c7 why doesn't take root take c7 word
yes yeah nice 96 just blocks so we need
to make a precise move before we could
take on c7 yes yes what yeah root G
seven check King King h8 and now yes and
Luke takes three seven is mate
surprisingly it's very unusual to see
the light was blocking the seventh rank
and therefore giving checkmate with two
bishops so yes the rook so remember this
position because this will be useful for
the last study so let's now move on to
study number two which it's a little
different
therefore the solution will change a
little bit how did you find Queen eight
six I don't even know G takes a sixth
Bishop takes F
King age 7 I'll obviously now obviously
the first moves are simple because
they're practicing the windmill idea but
but but we have to we have to find a key
solution to actually find mate in this
position the first moves were easy but
often the second third moves are the
critical ones and usually these are
silent moves yes if the silent move is
basically a move which is not forcing
not giving a check but sets up a great
tactical idea or sets up a mating threat
so so group g7 with g7 check obviously
King h8 and now there's a brilliant idea
yes yeah it's like to move I'm given
with yes
what did you say look at 7 know who says
e5 raise your hand if you think a 5 is
the winning one two a three a four or
five six B five yes II five is the
silent deadly move even though what is
what if black gives the check what if
they check us you didn't expect that did
we yes
yeah but surprisingly we defend with a
mating move you don't see that all the
time pretty amazing to see a mating
defensive move that's how strong
windmills are this is the third study
and final study
please black obviously is cramped so he
decides to take on c3 now fire verse
starts Queen a6 g6
bishop takes f6 here obviously this is
the kind of like to be a physician of
the windmill but we can use our rope
through full effect to close in the
black queen so we might want to position
our rook at a place where it will close
very close that's clean from hitting our
King so what should our next move be
yeah
yes root G 7 root g 7 King h8 yes yeah
rook takes f7 King g8 yes yes King h8
and how do you continue look a 7 that
actually doesn't block the Queen because
this queen is putting annoying pressure
on our phones we want to stop that yes
yes with b7 e g8 and now as the Queen is
block block we can give an even more
powerful check yes yes this should be
three now that we block the Queen from
protecting the d5 square we can give a
check with the bishop
so if black plays Bishop f7 how will he
get made it yes
yes engage 7y a continued g6 yeah King
g8 yes yes yes yes I'm listening
yes anyone else sees mate in sphere
moves
yes group g7 King h8 yeah
King g8 so we can see that the rook is a
tireless worker in this game as it gives
millions of check and in the end mate so
that's what happens if Bishop f7 is
played so d5 Bishop takes d5 Knight e6
now Luke g7 is played King f8 and now
comes a brilliant move the silent
brilliant move that actually will make
black the white bishop takes the Queen
but then the g7 rook is not well
defended enough and we lose it
yes yes back there oh I thought you
raised your hand yes exactly
brilliant idea what would be your next
move with white know what would be
wife's next move
yes so this is a brilliant idea of fun
congrats for finding it actually after
but it's lost for black now surprisingly
like is a queen up but he's totally lost
if black plays Queen d8 there's may
into I tell you made into in this
position how could I should like
continue yes seven we take a seven yes
[Music]
no yes yes what for Mooji eight mate
yeah Ruby g8 mate so surprisingly and
there's no way that black can stop mate
even though it's just the power of two
bishops rook and upon the bishop okay
what should my play if black takes yes
the Bishop e7 still mates and if black
plays rook a seventh
he's still trying he's still trying to
survive but this will fail because of
yes you're risen yes yes Lukey seven
Andrew g8 so black and this hopeless
situation gives away the bishop but
we're not scared we're taking the bishop
if black would play King e8 how would
King g8 lose it again
a silent winning move yes work eight
seven surprisingly there's no way to
carry route 88 mate so the sad King has
to go the other way and now
we give a check King h8 rook c7 King g8
and it's obviously will not take a draw
because we have beautiful bishops in the
center a dominating rook and how can we
win this game there's a pawn promotion
yes a 7 check black needs to take yeah
and Queens or oak but Queen is kind of
nicer and white wins the game with the
windmill idea thank you so much for
paying attention and learning about
windmills thank you
[Music]